if you've been paying attention to the
news recently you may have noticed that
many of the big stories revolve around
questions of race
increasingly in this country race is the
headline just this week
roseanne barr was fired and her show was
canceled on abc after she tweeted an
attack on valerie jarrett
that many described as racist starbucks
the coffee retailer closed more than 8
000 of its retail stores in order to
re-educate its white employees
about their unconscious racism meanwhile
a bar in portland oregon hosted a
reparations happy hour where
non-white patrons drank for free over in
cable newsland
msnbc aired an hour-long prime time
special that not only attacked racism
but also engaged in it by stereotyping
an entire group of people based on their
skin color
here's a selection from that the
gentrifiers of today their parents or
their grandparents ran away from the
city
to get away from black and brown food
and now their children and their
grandchildren are saying oh the suburbs
there's only so many olive gardens i can
go to so i need to go back to the city
and get my life in the city but when i
do that i need to have my hot yoga
studio in my pottery studio
and my stuff represented and if you
intrude on that
i will then call the police
well more and more it feels like racial
division is the subtext of virtually
everything in this country even topics
that seem unrelated to ethnicity
suddenly
are racially fraught the effect of all
that is a deeply angry and divided
nation but also you may have noticed
a terrified one many americans are
scared to say what they really think
about just about
anything one false word and you can be
denounced on twitter and
lose your livelihood it happens we see
it all the time
best just to smile and nod and hope the
witch hunt passes
how long do we have to live this way and
how did we get here in the first place
joining us now who is someone who has
paid attention closely for a long time
peter curse now a lawyer who serves on
the u.s commission on civil rights and
has written a new thriller called second
strike
which i can tell you firsthand is
excellent peter thanks a lot for joining
us
always my pleasure tucker so there's
something strange going on
even as the country becomes much more
diverse
and that was a trend that we were
promised would make the country more
harmonious
the country seems much more on edge
about questions of race what is going on
well i think several things are going on
but the overriding thing
is a political narrative that's driven
to enhance
one argument or the side of one
particular side
and it has its genesis in two things
first is the political imperative of
getting
democrats elected chiefly and so we have
a lot of this division on the basis of
race because there are no policy
prescriptions anymore if you've listened
very closely you don't hear
any workable policy prescriptions or
very few workable policy prescriptions
but what you hear a lot of
is identity politics i've been in the
u.s commission on civil rights in 17
years and in that 17 years we haven't
had more
lucid conversations about race or
identity
they have gotten increasingly soft mark
they've gotten increasingly opaque
and they're driven by an a historical
narrative one that doesn't have
or very little bearing on what truly
happened the united states of america
look
the fact of the matter is that in my
lifetime
matters of race and racial
discriminations have gotten demonstrably
better in ways that we could
never even imagine if you look at the
interaction
between individuals of various races
today
they've never been better individuals of
races but when you come to
right the interaction between groups
it's become hostile and toxic
and it's a function of trying to get
certain groups to have an allegiance to
a certain movement or certain party for
a political imperative
may i stop you there and just get back
up for a second to address something
that you said that i'd never thought of
the conversation is increasingly general
and less specific
so whereas 30 years ago people might say
in order to
close the achievement gap in
standardized testing we need to put more
money into head start
for example now the conversation is
this group is bad it has always been bad
it will never get better
why are we hearing fewer solutions than
we used to hear
well i think for a couple of reasons one
again is that political imperative
because solutions argue against
having a political advantage but i think
it's also because
there's a tendency on the part of some
to shout down others to cast others
as the other and again as for political
imperative but
you're afraid to say things that are
demonstrably
true to give you one example a couple of
weeks ago we had a hearing at the u.s
commission on civil rights
all-day hearing people from the justice
department police chiefs association you
name it everybody in the world was there
and the usual groups were there
it was a hearing on hate crimes because
of the ostensible spike in hate crimes
since trump has been elected
but facts are stubborn things and when
you take a look at the data and when i
ask
questions of this after everyone made
these grand pronouncements about how
horrible and horrific
the spike in hate crimes is we had no
hard evidence of such spike and the best
data on this comes from the bureau of
justice statistics
which has shown for for the last 30
years there has been a decline
in hate crimes there's a decline in all
manner of discrimination for more than
30 years
yet we have greater sensitivity
heightened sensitivity and you have to
ask yourself
this i i why this is this is the case i
think to some extent
it's because it helps the agenda
of certain groups of certain parties or
certain individuals
so you keep hearing that we need to have
an honest conversation on race and i'm
always for conversations particularly
for honest ones
but i wonder after all these
conversations if the country is becoming
more divided maybe that's not evidence
that is not working do we need to talk
less about race or more about race does
the conversation idea hold up
to scrutiny two things one is trucker i
disagree that we're having conversations
we always hear that we need to have a
conversation but what we get is
harangues and the rings usually come
from one side
and most decent people kind of duck
their heads and watch out for
incoming fire they don't want to get
caught in the crossfire
and you know if you go to colleges law
schools almost any institution of higher
learning and frankly k through 12
there are only certain acceptable
opinions that you can have there are
students who are punished and they know
this and they know
precisely how to react in the the
context
of a a classroom debate ostensibly on
race
there's only one acceptable opinion and
you're not allowed to offer other
opinions and that doesn't
forward the conversation and one other
point no and it doesn't help anybody
it doesn't help anybody i can see why
they try to shout you down
by the way but i'm glad that you came
thanks very much peter chris now great
to see you